da kann man sehen schildern Sie uns die
Situation aus ihrem Landkreis aus
Fürstenfeldbruck ich habe gerade gesagt
hört ihr uns überhaupt haben Sie das
Gefühl im Moment von der Bundesregierung
gehört zu werden mit der flüchtlingslage
bei Ihnen
also wir werden allmählich gehört aber
nicht von der Bundesregierung leider es
gab ja auf dreimalige Anschreiben die
ich als Präsident des bayerischen
Landkreistages an den Bundeskanzler
gerichtet habe nie auch nur eine
Reaktion von von Gott wird meine
Fürstenfeldbruck immer immer gehört
auch unsere Hilfe wenn man irgendwo
unterwegs ist dann heißt da wie geht's
denn mit deinen Flüchtlingen also seine
Anteilnahme aus der Bevölkerung aber die
Bundesregierung nimmt es leider kaum zu
kennt das ist gab es einen
flüchtlingsgipfel der Innenministerin
aber das ergebnislos nichts richtig
rausgekommen ja das heißt schildern sie
schildern Sie unseren Zuschauern ein
bisschen die Lage wie viele Flüchtlinge
haben sie in den vergangenen Monaten im
vergangenen Jahr beispielsweise
aufgenommen bei sich ja wir haben
zunächst mal aus so keine sehr viele
Flüchtlinge aufgenommen das war im
vergangenen Jahren sehr viele heißt
knapp 2000 in unserem Landkreis das sind
allerdings 800 privat untergekommen
dann ist es etwas zurückgegangen und
gegen Ende des Jahres 22 sind dann die
übrigen Fluchtrouten wieder benutzt
worden angereichert um die Türkei und
einige andere Staaten die wir also von
2015 her schon kennen ja und seitdem
sind wir immer intensiver auf der Suche
nach Unterkünften aber wir sind
eigentlich jetzt am Limit das heißt am
Limit was bedeutet das vor Ort sind
Turnhallen belegt haben sie Zelte
aufgemacht beispielsweise also
Turnhallen belege ich deshalb nicht weil
es außenturnhallen ja sozusagen keinen
weiteren Weg mehr gibt das war 2015
anders da war das eine Übergangslösung
und in der Folgezeit hat man dann
Unterkünfte akquiriert das geht jetzt
nicht mehr das heißt wir stellen dann in
der Tat jetzt Zelte auf oder haben Sie
schon aufgestellt
und das ist natürlich auch eine
Situation wo man sich fragen muss ob das
die Menschen die zu uns kommen
eigentlich so sich vorgestellt haben als
es geht nicht nur um die Überlastung der
Kommunen sondern auch um die Frage ist
das eigentlich das was die Menschen sich
erwartet haben weil
ist keine ordentlichen Umstände gibt
weil sie die Menschen nicht versorgen
können weil sie die Menschen schon gar
nicht integrieren werden können
alles dieses richtig
wer jemals in früherer Zeit bei der
Bundeswehr oder irgendwo war weiß wie es
ist in einem Zelt mit vielen anderen
Menschen Hausen zu müssen ohne
Privatsphäre mit schlechten klimatischen
Bedingungen mit Lärm und so weiter das
ist an sich schon an der Grenze des noch
menschenwürdigen ist ähnliches gilt für
gewerbehalten oder sonstige Sporthallen
die menschenwürdig oder würden Sie sagen
hier und da ist das unterhalb also es
erreicht eigentlich die Grenze ja
natürlich ist man froh wenn man es ist
das dringender Verfolgung sich zu uns
flüchtet wenn man einige Tage da
Aufnahme findet in so einer Unterkunft
aber es ist natürlich nichts mehr was
man sich vorstellt als irgendwo eine
Dauerlösung ja also aus diesem Grund
meinen wir können eigentlich nichts
vernünftiges mehr zur Verfügung stellen
es hätte waren würden sie dann kann man
sie in einem Landkreis sagen sie können
auch mehr aufnehmen
ich würde ihm erstmal sagen dass das
natürlich großartig ist was er dort
leistet als Landrat in der Gegend und
das trifft er für alle Kommunen in
Deutschland zu die natürlich im Jahr
2022 1,5 Millionen geflüchtete
aufgenommen haben insgesamt in
Deutschland das ist eine enorme Zahl
unterstellt Deutschland da stellt
insbesondere die Kommunen vor gewaltige
Herausforderung das muss man ganz klar
benennen hat der kann man sehen ja
genauso geschildert und er sagt wir
finden keine Unterkünfte mehr sagen Sie
jetzt würden Sie sagen er muss halt
weiter aufnehmen oder würden Sie sagen
jetzt ist in Fürstenfeldbruck erstmal
Stopp na ich würde sagen dass der Bund
mal anfangen muss seine Hausaufgaben zu
machen und dass sie Ampel Koalition
endlich liefern soll also der der
migrationsgipfel oder der
Integrationsgipfel den Professor
eingerufen hat hat zu nichts geführt
werden im Regen gelassen das stimmt und
ist gleichzeitig wunderbar um konkret
denn hier geht's ganz konkret um weitere
Flüchtlinge ganz konkret muss er Karma
sehen mit seinen Bürgermeister mit dem
Kommunen organisieren dass die Menschen
unterkommen das hat er ganz lange ganz
toll geschafft und jetzt
ist gerade die Grenze erreicht in
Fürstenfeldbruck würden sie jetzt sagen
weitere Flüchtlinge aufnehmen oder ist
dort Stopp der das muss er natürlich
einschätzen wie die Situation vor Ort
ist aber ich will ja sagen ich meine es
gibt etwas was der bundleisten muss um
den geflüchteten zur Seite zu stehen und
um den Kommunen zu Seite zu stehen um
genau diese Umstände abzumindern und
gleichzeitig können die Kommunen
natürlich auch andere Dinge machen ich
möchte verweisen auf das was die
Sozialsenatorin hier in Berlin gemacht
hat die Linke Sozialsenatorin katja
Kipping die hat die wohnverpflichtung
z.B aufgehoben was heißt das eben
Menschen dann da tatsächlich auch die in
diesem sammeln Unterkünften
untergebracht sind auch das Anrecht
haben bei Freundinnen oder Verwandten
unterzukommen also im privaten Wohnung
das hat hier in Berlin zu einer enormen
Entspannung der Situation geführt und
darüber können natürlich Kommunen an
dieser Stelle auch nachdenken weil es
hier in Berlin z.B erfolgreich
funktioniert das heißt der Bund muss
liefern er muss die Kommunen vor allem
finanziell unterstützen wir haben ganz
großen Lärche sondern Notstand wenn es
um Wohnung also im
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten überhaupt
geht aber auch die Infrastruktur muss
natürlich ausgebaut werden dafür braucht
es für Investitionen in den Kommunen
überall da muss der Bund Nachschärfung
gleichzeitig können die Kommunen auch
selber noch etwas tun würde ihn und kann
man die wohnen Verpflichtung aufzuhören
würde ihnen das jetzt helfen also der
der Wohnungsmarkt dass er jetzt rund um
München nicht wahnsinnig entspannt
gerade ja seit Jahrzehnten ich würde
Ihnen das jetzt helfen wenn man sagt
also privat
werden jetzt mehr Unterkünfte zur
Verfügung gestellt das war sehr schöne
waren gerade gesagt hat und es gibt oben
drauf noch ein bisschen mehr Geld dann
wäre das Problem gelöst
das ist ein theoretischer Ansatz es ist
bei uns nicht so dass wir sehr viele
Menschen haben die jetzt Flüchtlinge aus
Afrika oder aus Nordafrika einfach
aufnehmen würden bei der keine war das
etwas leichter mit dem privaten Aufnahme
da ist es sehr schwierig und die andere
Seite ist es wird immer gesagt man muss
jetzt Wohnungen bauen da haben wir ein
Problem der Bund wünscht sich das aber
die Gemeinden sind zuständig und die
Gemeinden wollen nicht so stark wachsen
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass sie
keine Flüchtlinge mögen sondern sie
haben auch für Münchner Menschen keine
Wohnungen in diesem Ausmaß gebaut welche
nicht so stark wachsen wollen und Sie
werden es jetzt auch nicht tun für
Menschen aus Kabul oder Aleppo würde es
Ihnen helfen wenn die Bundesregierung
gerade sagen würde bei ihnen im
Landkreis und in einigen anderen
Landkreisen machen wir jetzt einmal
Stopp wir lassen sie einmal durchatmen
bei ihnen im Moment kein weiterer Zuzug
ja das würde mir helfen aber das
wünschen sich nahezu alle Kommunen und
Landkreise in der Republik und deswegen
würde ich da nicht Verbrechen wir haben
alle das gleiche Schicksal und es gibt
eigentlich ganz wenige Landkreise die
noch in der Lage sind sozusagen kommt
alle zu uns die anderen brauchen jetzt
mal eine Pause das ist überall gleich
und deswegen glaube ich teilen wir auch
das solidarisch
ich habe zu Beginn gesagt die Frage
taucht immer wieder auf hört ihr uns
immer im Moment überhaupt jetzt hören
wir die Schilderung von einem Karma
sehen und merken gleichzeitig eigentlich
hilft ihm nur eins nämlich im Moment
einmal stoppt zu sagen einmal atmen zu
lassen und die große
Aufnahmebereitschaft dadurch vielleicht
auch nicht dauerhaft kaputt zu machen
ist das die Lösung im Moment
ein Satz vorweg
wir sind ja in Deutschland am dritter
Stelle
auf der Welt mit der Anzahl derer
Flüchtlinge die lieber aufnehmen das ist
auch wichtig so und wir brauchen das
Asylrecht und wir brauchen auch die
Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention aber
aus meiner Sicht haben wir seit
2015/2016 nicht die richtigen Weichen
gestellt und nichts dazugelernt das ist
das Problem wir haben uns immer darauf
fokussiert zu sagen das muss an der
europäischen Außengrenze passieren mit
Frontex dort wo sie ankommen die
Bewerber müssen sie auch entsprechend
ankerzentren auch durchgeschleust werden
entsprechend auch juristisch
durchgeschleust werden in der selbst
auch Jurist weiß dann was man ja machen
kann wenn man mal ein Verfahren
hinauszögern will das wäre das richtige
aber es ist nicht passiert und wenn man
sich heute anschaut was ich sehr
tragisch finde dass Europa gar nicht
miteinander arbeitet und dass man daran
arbeiten muss dass sie es tun aber
sicherlich dauern wird das hat auch mit
Regierungen zu tun die wir in Europa
haben kann ich nur sagen wir müssen
leider leider eine Lösung jetzt für
Deutschland bringen jetzt gibt es
bereits Grenzkontrollen nach Österreich
rüber Bayern Österreich in die anderen
Bereichen nicht wenn ich sehe sie haben
es vorher selbst gesagt tausend am Tag
30.000 die kommen wenn ich weiß dass in
Istanbul es Reisebüros gibt wie man am
besten als Kurde als Afghane oder als
Syrer hierherkommt und ich nicht sagen
will dass sie nicht alle verfolgt sind
aber dass die über diese sogenannten
Reisebüros nach Serbien geflogen werden
dann in Bussen bis zur österreichischen
Grenze kommen über einen Zaun steigen
und dann illegal hier sind dann kann ich
nur sagen dann müssen was wir können das
in dem Fall nicht belegen woher diese
Videos kommen welchen Ort die genau
zeigen die werden bei tiktok
beispielsweise gepostet und die zeigen
dann immer wieder dieselben Szenen wenn
man klein zusammen ist von diesen
Grenzen leiterranen Schleuser sind dort
am Werk und dann sieht man eben relativ
einfach wie man den Weg durch Europa
eben fortsetzen kann ist kursieren
hunderte dieser Videos im Netz das ist
der von ihnen gerade beschriebene Weg
der ist es gerade nicht mehr Wochen
dauert
es ist kein Urlaub es ist tragen das
will ich ja nicht denen unterstellen die
es tun aber das sind in der Regel
Mittelschicht Personen aus diesen
Ländern das kostet ja fünf bis sieben
Euro mindestens herzukommen ich fand der
Bilder nicht belegen können es geht aber
glaube ich eher Schilder waren
tatsächlich um was anderes geht um den
Grenzschutz an der Stelle und ob
irgendwo irgendjemand kontrolliert
gerade wer da kommt ja und deshalb bin
ich der Auffassung dass wir im Moment
den Grenzschutz brauchen wir müssen
vorübergehen die Menschen schließen in
Deutschland ja um zu vermeiden dass das
was wir hier sehen jetzt auch weiterhin
diese Auswüchse hat wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass außerhalb unseres Gebietes
die Verfahren durchgeführt werden wie es
Dublin 3 eigentlich immer vorgesehen hat
wie es in Europa passieren muss damit
diese Schleuser Richtung aufhören das
geht nur mit einer kleinen
Kontrollen wo würden sie die durchfahren
komplett an den deutschen Grenzen und
Flughäfen ist das durch die
Bundespolizei durch die Landespolizei
ist das leistbar davon gehe ich aus ist
es ja in den letzten Jahren noch
aufgestockt worden noch unter der alten
Koalition in Berlin und im übrigen gibt
es auch Länder Polizei und andere gerade
in meinem Heimatland wir liegen ja an
der Grenze zu Frankreich ist das möglich
dort werden Stichpunkte Stichproben
gemacht ist aber natürlich zu wenig das
mag alles hart klingen aber die Realität
zeigt es geht im Moment nicht mehr
anders und ich möchte auch noch einen
Aspekt dazu bringen wenn sie Menschen in
Zelten unterbringen 24 Stunden 7 Tage
die Woche dann brauchen Sie eine ganze
Menge Personal im Jugendamt in anderen
Bereichen und sie müssen ja auch schauen
dass der soziale Aspekt eine Rolle
spielt das wird im Moment leider leider
nicht anders gehen weil Ungarn
Frankreich und viele andere Länder gar
nicht
hier in Deutschland bzw Schafe
Grenzkontrollen sie haben ein bisschen
Lächeln auf dem Gesicht sie wollen das
nicht das betrachte ich wirklich sehr
skeptisch was der Kollege da gerade sagt
minder Situation zu tun dass erstens im
Vergleich zu 20 15 z.B viel weniger
geflüchtete aus den Krisengebieten wie
Afghanistan und dann Kriegsgebiet wie
Syrien nach Deutschland oder Europa
insgesamt stimmt ja gesehen sind die
Zahlen genauso wie sie sie beschrieben
haben wenn man die letzten Monate sich
anguckt das ist das was er kann man aus
Fürstenfeldbruck ja auch geschildert hat
sind die Zahlen dabei sich denen von
damals anzunähern was ich nicht möchte
und davor muss ich wirklich warnen auch
in der Debatte hier an dieser Stelle ist
erstens das geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
ausgespielt würden werden gegen
geflüchtete aus anderen kriegs- dafür
waren das passiert mittlerweile hier in
jeder Talkshow wird immer gewarnt davor
es ist aber noch nie passiert wir wissen
davon gar nicht wahr doch weil der
Kollege von der CDU ja unter anderem
auch Partei Genosse und Genossen äh
Kolleginnen und Kollegen natürlich an
dieser Stelle hat die dafür werben dass
das Asylrecht geschliffen wird und dass
solche Grenzkontrollen außerhalb der
Europäischen Union z.B mit dir dubiosen
Partnern wie den libyschen Milizen und
so weiter jetzt ganz kurz zu fragen die
Frage war ja relativ einfach und sie
haben gesagt sie sind skeptisch wenn es
um Grenzkontrollen geht in Deutschland
warum
wir leben in der Europäischen Union das
führt dazu dass dann gezielt sozusagen
Menschen nicht deutscher Herkunft oder
nicht europäischer Herkunft untersucht
werden rausgezogen er hat er auch gerade
von Stichproben geredet das ist
klassisches racial Profiling das geht
doch überhaupt nicht das ist doch ein
Unding ich finde das tatsächlich in der
Debatte die Größe bewahrt werden muss
wenn wir darüber reden wie Integration
gelingen kann die Aufnahme gelingen kann
und wir sind uns sehr in der
Problemanalyse einig sozusagen und darin
dass viel mehr passieren muss aber dann
müssen wir doch auch darüber reden wie
das gelingen kann auf der Wahrung der
Grundrechte und auch das Asylrecht ist
und wir eben nicht in so einem
rassistischen Set Weg verfallen wie er
gerade geschildert wird an dieser Stelle
dagegen verwahre ich mich sind
Kontrollen für Sie rassistisch nein aber
der Prozess des racial Profiling ist
rassistisch und der ist gerade sehr
bildhaft dargestellt worden das ist
natürlich Kontrollen an den Grenzen
geben muss an den Außengrenzen
Europäischen Union da sind wir uns ja
einig und das wird ja auch getan
sozusagen das reicht ja aber nicht nur
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie